So we've got sharpie gate, which we'll follow
up on a little bit later. It now appears that
it wasn't merely that Donald Trump held up
a sharpie modified hurricane map.
We're now getting reports from White House
insiders that Donald Trump personally sharpied
the hurricane map itself. There's one problem
with that claim, and I'll talk about it later
in the show, but before we even get to that,
Donald Trump had a completely separate and
crazed and erratic fit on Twitter over the
weekend starting about Barack Obama. Now remember
when Barack Obama was president? I know many
of you do. Republicans wouldn't stop saying,
Hey Democrats, George W. Bush isn't president
anymore. Don't mention George W. Bush. Just
talk about Barack Obama. No more talk about
Bush. I wish one of them would be intellectually
honest enough to give the same advice to Donald
Trump and republicans. Now, Barack Obama's
not president anymore. Hillary Clinton never
was president. Stopped talking about both
of them. Uh, but Donald Trump going off on
Twitter, on Barack Obama, shifting directly
from that Twitter tirade into yes, one related
to Hurricane Dorian and the map and fake news.
So disclaimer, before we get into this, I've
said before, many times we don't want to just
cover Trump tweets for the sake of covering
Trump tweets.
And we don't. And in fact today I'm going
to skip over a ton of them because they're
not really related. It's, there's tweets that
are differently incoherent, which are not
particularly relevant to the story we're talking
about today. Today I'm going to focus on specifically
Trump's tweets about Obama and the Alabama
stuff and fake news. Now, all of what I'm
going to show you happened basically within
24 hours, not even early this weekend. So
understand this is sort of about the content
of the tweets, but this is happening in one
day. This is one day of some of Donald Trump's
tweets. This is the president. Look at the
emotional instability. Look at the amount
of time that is being spent tweeting falsehoods
instead of being president. So let's just
jump right into it. Starting off with the
immigration stuff and Obama, the migration
lines to Tutes, Christopher Hage, Jack says,
the Supreme Court has to look at whether DACA
is lawful.
What they are looking at now is whether Trump's
rescission of DACA is lawful, must consider
lawfulness of DACA itself. Looks very odd
that president Trump doesn't have the discretion
to end the program that President Obama began
in his discretion already. I mean, the language
is crazy. It's all crazy. That program was
unlawful to begin with. I think it's very
unlikely that the Supreme Court is going to
issue an order reinstating what it believes
is an unlawful program. DACA is unlawful.
President Obama never had the legal right
to sign DACA and he indicated so at the time
of signing. But in any event, how can he have
the right to sign? And I don't have the right
to unsigned, totally illegal document, which
would actually give the president new powers.
DACA will be going before the Supreme Court.
It is a document that even President Obama
didn't feel he had the legal right to sign.
He signed it anyway. I mean this is incoherent
folks. Rest assured that if the supreme court
does what all say, it must based on the law,
a bipartisan deal will be made to the benefit
of all. So this is the Obama DACA rant and
it makes no sense at all. Obama didn't sign
DACA. It was a presidential memo to expand
something that already existed. There are
more details, but this is not a story about
immigration. It is about the unhinged and
unstable nature of the president. So there
are four tweets. They're just rants. They
mean nothing of substance. But as followers
see that as strong leadership, believe it
or not. So then a few hours go by and Donald
Trump tweets about the fed, another popular
target going from slamming Obama to slamming
the Fed saying quote, I agree with Jim Kramer.
The Fed should lower rates. They were way
too early to raise and way too late to cut
and big dose quantitative tightening didn't
exactly help either.
Where did I find this guy, Jerome? Oh, well,
you can't win them all. So when he says, where
did I find this Guy Jerome? He's talking about
fed chief Jerome Powell, who of course Trump
picked after bragging that one of the hallmarks
of his administration would be appointing
the best people. If Jerome's not great, then
it's on Trump. Now we're up to five tweets.
Then he tweets some compliments about Fox
News people, Sarah Huckabee, Sanders, and
Yuliya contributor, Jeanine Pirro. I'm not
even including those. Then he goes back to
the hurricane and remember, this is all the
same day quote. The fake news media was fixated
on the fact that I properly said at the beginnings
of Hurricane Dorian that in addition to Florida
and other states, Alabama may also be grazed
or hit. They went capital c crazy hoping against
hope that I made a mistake, which I didn't
check out maps.
This nonsense has never happened to another
president because other presidents aren't
doing what you're doing. Four days of corrupt
reporting still without an apology, but there
are many things that the fake news media has
not apologized to me for like the witch Hunter
Spygate, the lame stream media and their Democrat
partner should start playing it straight.
It would be so much better for our country.
So we're now up to eight tweets. Once again,
sort of amalgamating the issues of so-called
fake news, the hurricane Dorian fiasco, making
himself out to be the victim and martyr and
calling the Russia probe a hoax conspiracy.
This is still one day Friday. Then tweet nine
in this series is Trump again attacking the
so called fake news quote. The economy is
great. The only thing adding to quote uncertainty
is the fake news. That's tweet nine and it's
still September 6th and I'm not including
the ones about Piro and Sanders, and then
he goes into false statements about tariffs.
Quote China just enacted a major stimulus
plan with all the tariffs they are paying
to the USA. Billions and billions of dollars
they need it. In the meantime, our Federal
Reserve sits back and does nothing. Now, of
course, China doesn't pay the tariffs. American
companies buying Chinese stuff pay the tariffs
and then they pass on the cost of those tariffs
onto you and me. American consumers. That's
the 10th tweet and these are just the policy
ones again. He also spent half the day tweeting
compliments to a variety of Fox News hosts.
Stop talking about Obama. Stop lying about
how tariffs work. Stop lying about investigative
journalism being fake news. Stop lying about
Hurricane Dorian. Trump is trying to bully
society and the economy into some kind of
stupid submission by attacking media and using
Twitter and they're not fully submitting to
him. Some enclaves have submitted to Trump.
That's sad. That's disappointing. If we do
not vote this out in November of 2020 we deserve
another four years of this as a society. Now
I know the people who vote for someone else,
they don't personally deserve it, but if as
a country we can not eradicate the type of
pseudo and anti intellectual ism and non-thinking
hyper-partisan a a sticking like glue to this
in competent man, then as a society, as a
country, we ultimately will deserve another
four years of this, which is what we might
do.
Yeah. Let me know what you think about all
of this. Are you just depressed? Are you experiencing
something else? I'm on Twitter at the pacman.
The show is on Twitter at David
Pakman show,